[Music]
hello and welcome to this video in this
video we will be talking about the
repertoire choice against the Catalan
the Catalan is a combination of the
moves d4c for ng3 so a typical wave on
white to play would be like this one
play G 3 on the 4th move as we will see
we will reach a position
this one that could also happen from 93
first d5 and then G 3 the Catalan is
important to study and the main reason
why it is important to study is that the
popularity of the opening has increased
quite a bit on the top level you see it
very frequently and it has definitely
become yeah more I think even maybe a
more principled choice on the top level
then some Queen's Gambit lines because
white is not getting anywhere in these
and the Catalan is not as let's say
heavily analyzed yet it is already quite
a bit of theory on on the top level they
then have analyzed them to an enormous
depth there as well but it's not
comparable to some Queen's Gambit lines
and what the top guys play is relevant
for every level because people will
imitate even if you are in a club game
people will still adapt what they seem
from from people like dinger n or
Caruana or every top player has the
Catalan basically in their repertoire in
particularly of course if they if they
start d4 in the first place so what to
play against the Catalan yeah
unsurprisingly
we need to play d5 yeah white can also
man here we would have more options even
a play c5 or give the check but as some
said perform a common move order is this
so we are committed to d5 so after g3 we
will play d5 and now White has the
mentioned choice to play Bishop g2 fall
first or Knight f3 first and the
difference is relatively minor between
the two moves it will often simply
transpose to the same thing
our main move as it is structured here
in the chapter of this course is Knight
f3 simply because he will meet this
position more often due to them mention
move order with Knight f3 being played
first so let's have a look at Bishop g2
against Bishop g2 just as we will play
against Knight f3
we will play Bishop to b4 check yeah
this is um I think very attractive
choice for black and the reason why I
think this is because it's a very good
it hits a sweet spot in a way this line
is very sound and well respected from a
theoretical point of view it is played
by my many top players so it is a sound
and very very good line objectively
speaking and it I think also offers of
like some chances to win the game
because the resulting positions will
often be rather complex so we don't have
many early priest trades and many lines
for example so I think it's a good it's
a good choice as a practical weapon and
also considering it's very good
theoretical standing then idea of the
check is that white now obviously have
three possible replies and um every
reply has a bit of a drawback and we
will look at them one by one we start
with the move Knight c3 this is not a
move that you will probably encounter
here very often but it is it has some
additional relevance because the
position that you have now could easily
arise from annum so Indian I want to
show this if you have the nihms ohm and
wide now place the move g3 you would get
to the same line this is exactly the
same position so we have a ready-made
answer let's say against the g3 name
though if we study the bishop before
line it can lead to the same positions
so Knight c3 we will castle
and now White has a fundamental choice
he can keep offering this pawn or you
can take on d5 I mean after 90 of three
people we will grab the pawn so it sets
the main line him so sometimes white
wants to avoid that and takes on d5 this
doesn't really bother us at all we can
of course simply take and now I'm set up
a position with c6 and rook e8 this is a
very healthy position very good
development we have no problem peace
that's important this for example can
easily develop to f5 and it is not so
clear what White's Bishop is doing on g2
this is a common problem if the bishop
is Venkat out and it faces his pawn wall
that can't be an issue sometimes to
generate some play um I think here we
can simply stop and conclude that Black
is fine it is a bit more frequently seen
that white keeps the tension in place
Knight f3 and here there's more than one
possible way to play here but I think
the most principled one and best one is
to take just take the pawn and ask white
about his intentions how do you want to
get this back this is not that easy and
this is a typical thing when the knight
is on C 3 it can be easier to get the
pawn back if for example you could
attack it with Queen c2 or Queen a4 in
some in some cases this is how the pawn
is often recovered in the classical
Catalan main lines here the knight on c3
is stopping this idea we have chances to
keep the pawn or in some cases return it
because white needs to spend time to get
it back so um right now um usually
castles that looks very logical just get
the King out and pin the knight and then
see how to get it back now um it's
important to remember the setup that we
play him we should play knight c6 this
is the most active
this was a free preview of our entire
1.d4 course based on the nimzo-indian
and rock gozen available on chess about
calm thanks for watching and see you
soon
[Music]